you don't [ __ ] your dogs
that's bad
[Music]
hey guys i'm annie letterman i'm back to
answer the internet i didn't bring my ab
makeup this time it sucks um if you
could put any franchise restaurant in
your house what would it be red
[ __ ] lobster baby no i want to
i want a tank i want
cheddar biscuits i'd eat those in bed
you know you all would
wouldn't you guys would you put your
dick in a cheddar biscuit um is there
something that makes you automatically
swipe right on tinder um
when a guy says here's my wife
not into it not into it please if you
have a wife do not hit on me what is the
one thing someone can say that makes you
immediately hate them um
the n-word
is eiffel towering a chick with another
guy gay um
no i think it's straight you know
because when i eiffel tower over them
it's like pretty like i'm gazing into
his eyes so it's pretty like hetero if
you had to move it to a different place
on your body where would you put your
vagina maybe my nipples i would cut it
in two and have it right here and then
when the milk comes out it's like
would you rather
a never get oral sex ever again b
get only oral sex for the rest of your
life um oral let's do it i don't have to
worry about pregnancy safe sex um
you're literally asking me if i'm a
lesbian you're like you're asking me
like would you be a lesbian this doesn't
say this doesn't say wait never get or
only or oh so you can only have oral sex
like all day you don't get food anymore
no water only oral sex that's it i'm
just walking around with a guy in my
between my legs would you rather watch
your dad [ __ ] a 100 year old man or
watch your mother kill someone um well i
would just watch my dad [ __ ] the hundred
old man and then watch my mom kill the
man for [ __ ] her dude my mom really
are starting to go scarjo i know that's
always a comparison but as you're
getting guys on the side there's a
[ __ ] boner happening yo for real
though it's getting it's it's just i'm
happy i think it's honestly spray tan i
think it's spray tan that you're you're
feeling i think i was always pretty but
now you know i have money so you're more
attracted to me is eating in bed gross
is it is eating in bed gross no
i like it it keeps it like it keeps your
bed like kind of like ribbed you know
you got like little chips on you
no eat whatever you want you guys are
eating ass okay you guys are eating ass
i'm not an ass eater no no no it's fine
listen i have a hospital bed anyway my
boyfriend bangs me on the edge i sit on
the edge and then we bring the the
end up and then to his penis level i
present myself that's pretty cool yes
it's amazing everybody should try it the
four plays less we got to be like he's
going to be playing my nipples while i'm
going up you know but we do that so it's
like i can just
you eat in bed you get the crumbs you
just lift the bed up it falls over it's
gone get a dog by the way too the dog
will eat the food off your bed now your
ass i learned that mistake last time you
don't [ __ ] your dogs
that's bad would you put your kid in a
gorilla pit for 50 000
no why would your job is to protect your
kid you're going to put it for 50 grand
come on people we need to bring up our
money vibrations that is nothing now 5
million no there's no number i'm putting
my kid in
i'll be poor and protect my children
this is so sad literally has two
children i have no children two children
a billion no
but i guess i could put their kid i
could put the kids body back together
again all right if i could put the kid's
body back together again clone it would
you rather kill 25 kittens in a row or
one dog guys look driving down the
street if there's a litter of kittens
you're like
all at once come on a dog though oh i
don't have to kill any of these animals
okay i will chop up a cow and eat it for
dinner
i will i'll go to ikea and i'll eat the
[ __ ] out of a horse [ __ ] meat
meatball i don't give a [ __ ] sports
meatball well the ikea remember when
they found out there was horse meat in
the ikea things and i still went back
i'm like that's why they're so good but
i can't i look at my dog and i do look
at his little chicken thighs
i like to conquer fears but i think it
would have to be a situation where the
person before they died in their will
was like i want annie letterman to eat
me i would maybe taste it i would maybe
taste it also because if i don't know i
don't care at all so that's the thing
too if you could master one of the four
bases of sex but you'd have to be below
average at every other base which one
would you choose i feel like honestly
this is controversial but first base you
don't if you're a bad kisser you can't
get anywhere and i then you can kiss a
dick the way you kiss a mouth and i when
i think of bad k it's like they're i've
had bad kissers in my life and it's like
it it's such a deal breaker you can't
get horny there there's always like a
breath situation a teeth situation
they're making their lips really tight
yeah no my boyfriend has a joke will
come in like a tight mouth and i'm like
even as a joke i don't like butthole
mouth like i'm like
juice him up but he's got juicy lips who
is that guys it's so hard
but i can't read and i have louis
vuitton head to toe so um who is the one
person in the world you at least want to
bang your significant other
um probably one of his siblings you know
they're off limits they're mine
that's right walker boys i'm coming for
you
all right big thanks for watching ati
anybody else who you want to see any up
and coming comics anybody who you think
deserves to be a superstar comment below
we'll go get them make sure you
subscribe to the channel right now